listen as elizabeth moss turns off the
sink in this scene
now listen to it with a completely
different sound design
in the first version all sound cuts out
but that's a whole lot scarier
sound has been an important element in
film for a long time
but in horror movies it plays an even
bigger role
when it comes to like horror films you
don't give away the ghost you don't want
to give away the monster or the
or the moment that's leslie bloom
co-founder of alchemy post sound
and he just described the key difference
between regular foley sound
and what he does as a foley artist for
horror movies like the invisible man
normally foley focuses on sounds made by
characters you see
but in horror it's about the sounds of
the unseen character
someone or something that may be there
without the audience knowing for sure
that it is
[Music]
that's what ratchets up the suspense and
primes the audience for a truly
terrifying reveal
and maybe no film does this better than
the one with an invisible villain
take the simple sound of wind a staple
of horror movie sound design
whether it's curtains reacting to a rush
of air
or a flock of birds flapping against the
breeze
in a regular movie you might hear wind
when characters open a window
or walk outside but in horror movies
often the source of the sound won't be
clear
for this next part you might want to
grab your headphones
this scene signals the invisible man's
presence with mysterious whooshing
sounds
created by flapping an old shirt
you can't actually see where this wind
sound is coming from
but as elizabeth moss's character
cecilia approaches the sink
the whooshes build in intensity
and build
until each one sounds more like a rumble
still the window's closed and the
curtains look pretty still
so the sound suggests something's moving
inside the room
exactly where we don't know there's
another sound in the scene that confuses
our senses even more
hear those wind chimes
they're subtle but disorienting
especially because the sound isn't
coming from something you can point to
in the outside world see leslie uses
different kinds of wind chimes to
accentuate
tense moments in horror scenes
[Music]
even if there aren't any chimes in the
shot it could be that
that moment that you know somebody hears
a ring in their ears
that ringing in the ears is called a
subjective sound
something the characters hearing in
their mind
in horror movies subjective sound helps
place you inside the protagonist's head
so you identify with their fear then we
have the one that was actually used
in the invisible man it's how the fully
artist handles the chimes that makes a
sound creepy
this is what leslie calls a demented
wind chime
a sound alchemy made for the nighthouse
they created it by putting an old
telephone bell on a rope
and swinging it around the slower you
swing it
the creepier it gets
even the most common sounds require
special treatment in horror
movies like footsteps alchemy has a huge
shoe collection for this purpose
i know how each one of these shoes
reacts to every one of these floor
surfaces
in a non-horror movie you'll likely know
exactly where footstep sounds are coming
from
and how close they are to the central
character but in horror movies
sometimes the most effective footsteps
are barely audible
so you really have to strain to hear
them just as the protagonist is doing
to soften the footsteps of the invisible
man and match the sound of his neoprene
suit
leslie walked around with rubber gloves
over his feet
adding a yoga mat to mute the sounds
even more
the result you might not even be sure
you heard anything at all
that uncertainty is the bread and butter
of suspense in horror movies
barely perceptible sounds can make you
doubt your own
senses just like the character is
doubting theirs
and that makes the viewing experience
that much scarier
what places you even further into the
protagonist's shoes
literally is the sound of their
footsteps
she is like nervously shaking i'm gonna
try to portray that in her and her
movements in her footsteps
to play this up the artists at alchemy
don't use just any regular floor
i need old crappy wood i need
a really bad sub floor and i need really
crappy nails that are going to move
within the wood
leslie made a custom one that met all
those requirements
partly using 65 year old wood each
corner makes slightly different kinds of
creaky sounds
which emphasize the sense of
unsteadiness
like you're again literally on shaky
ground
to cap it all off there's this
the accent sound that's a sharp
pronounced sound that stands out against
the subtler
more ambient ones we've been hearing
indicating to the audience that
something is off leslie used an old sink
to create this unsettling squeak
but that came out sounding like too big
a piece of metal so he used a towel to
dampen the sound
but what really makes this
scarier than this
is the way everything else goes quiet
after the sink squeaks
it's not realistic for all the sounds to
suddenly stop
right when the faucet does but sound in
horror movies isn't always about realism
often it's about creating a heightened
reality it doesn't have to be
wall-to-wall sound all the time
having that that brief moment of just
silence
and then wham to me that's powerful
here the few moments of absolute quiet
put the audience on
edge right before the moment of attack
and when that moment does come the
contrast is that much stronger
i like to make this grab just a little
bit larger than life
let's get a grab on more skin we'll
layer the two of those together
and i want to throw in like a little bit
of creak just when she's getting lifted
up
that's a hit and a grab and the whole
nine yards so
you know she's in trouble now let's
watch another scene
and see how these suspense sounds play
out together the accent sound comes
earlier in this scene
in the form of a jarring phone ring
[Music]
the phone has an unnaturally loud echo
against the wood
and it's startling because of its
contrast with the otherwise quiet attic
but that's sort of a fake out because
afterwards we return to quiet
which can give the audience a sense of
false calm
cecilia's shaky creaky footsteps are
actually crawling sounds in this scene
which put the viewer right there with
her as she moves across the attic
leslie accentuated the sound of the
creaking floorboards
using his custom-made creak box
earlier we saw how subtle footsteps and
wishes signaled the bad guy's presence
here it's a faint rattle of a ladder in
the distance
she hears something
and it jars her
now we don't need climbing up the ladder
because that would be just
giving away the farm not too loud not
too big
he's trying to sneak up on her too
since all we hear is that rattle we
don't know exactly where the bad guy is
throwing our senses off yet again that's
crucial because it's priming us
for this jump scare
part of why that reveal is so terrifying
is because of the proximity of the
invisible man
by giving us minimal hints as to his
whereabouts the sound design tricked us
into thinking he was farther away
when he gets splashed with paint
at that point the cat's out of the bag
the big moment here called for some
bigger and messier sounds
we don't want to dump paint everywhere
but we need it to sound thick and gooey
the best tool for that are these scraps
of sheepskin
which leslie says are nastier than your
usual towel
or rag but it holds a ton of water in it
which gives it a very you know very
gooey visceral kind of sound to it
to maximize moments like this horror
movies have to walk a fine line
figuring out how to hide a character
while revealing them at the same time
they accomplish this with subtle foley
and sound design
[Music]
that goes beyond realism to create a
heightened reality
where your ears and mind are playing
tricks on you
don't let them haunt you hello